- So, before we close out the show,
I've got one last story
to give you all the feels.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
More than 25 years ago,
Jed was a high school
football player in Arizona
who earned his Letterman jacket.
He designed it himself
and was all ready to
pick it up at the store
when his mom confessed,
she just didn't have
the money to pay for it.
Jed understood and he
never got the jacket.
That is, until the end of last year,
when it serendipitously
came back into his life.
His tale is so amazing.
We have Jed on the line
to explain it right now.
What's up, Jed?
(audience applauds)
- Howdy, thanks for having me.
- Oh my god, this story is crazy.
Tell everybody how you ended up
with your jacket after decades.
- Well, back in high school,
I ordered a Letterman jacket.
When it was time to pick it up,
my mom couldn't afford it
and it wasn't that I was mad.
It was just another speed
bump that I had to get over
during my rough childhood.
We grew up with IOUs
under the Christmas tree
and my mother really had
trouble making ends meet.
Now, she did the best job
that she possibly could
and gave us nothing but love.
Fast forward to November of 2021.
27 years later, my big brother, Josh,
who lives three and a half hours
outside of where we grew up,
walks into a thrift store
and sees this jacket.
He calls me up and says,
"Dude, was there any other
Jeds at Chaparral in 1994?"
(Kelly laughs)
I said, "No," just one.
He sends me the picture.
I knew immediately that
that was my jacket.
He tells me that it was $25.
I said, "Buy that right now,
I'm flying home to see you."
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- When he put the jacket on me,
it was one of the
greatest days of my life.
- That's so cool.
(audience applauds)
Like, later on in life,
I bet it has so much more meaning now
than it would have even had
if you would have gotten
it back in the day.
That's so cool!
So deeper meaning, does it
have deeper meaning to you
than just getting the memento, right?
- Kelly, my mom was the most
religious person I've
ever come in contact with.
We went to church every Sunday.
She passed away back in 2012
and she told us that she would
always send us a sign from the other side.
A couple of weeks before this happened,
I was just telling a friend
that that never happened.
If this isn't a sign,
I don't know what is.
And, you know, was this
divine intervention?
I don't know.
But what I do know, is that
it gives me faith in humanity
and hope that anything is possible.
- I definitely think that's a sign, man.
That's the coolest story.
That's the coolest part,
that she told you that
she'd send you a sign
and then you ended up finding it.
What are the chances of that happening?
That's so cool.
Well, thank you so much, Jed.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Jed] Awesome.
- And that's not all, my man.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you.
So, they're going to be
writing you a check for $1000.
How's that?
(audience cheers)
- Thank you so much-
- [Kelly] Absolutely! Absolutely, man.